but first good evening and welcome to
tucker carlson here's a question what
happens when you crush entire sectors of
your own economy for nearly two years
and then
to compensate for your crime you decide
to inject trillions of dollars of
freshly printed cash into the system
what happens if you do that
well honestly we don't really know what
happens when you do that because no one
in history has ever been stupid enough
to try it it's going to be years before
we really understand the consequences of
all this of our government's reckless
coronavirus policy
but in the meantime we can say with
total confidence at the american economy
it's getting very weird
not all of it some of what we're seeing
isn't weird in the slightest it was in
fact entirely predictable if you create
trillions of us dollars out of nothing
us dollars are going to be worth less
much less this is called inflation and
we're suffering through it right now
inflation very simply is the result of
too much money in the system if you have
too much of something it's value fall
supply and demand remember
this is what's causing the rise in real
estate prices and of bitcoin and if
other assets that investors run to when
they no longer trust the country's
currency why can't you afford a house
right now simple because washington
printed too much money
no one should be surprised by this it's
a cycle as old as money itself
political leaders devalue the currency
for short-term gain in the end this
leads to long-term collapse
debasing the coinage that's what they
used to call it for example by the
middle of the third century the roman
denarius the silver coin was only about
two percent actual silver the rest of it
was just junk
within a few years not incidentally the
entire roman empire blew up and the
barbarians took over
but it wasn't just the romans who did
this every government devalues its
currency at some point they do it
because it's irresistible you can't not
do it if you do it you get free money
and you don't have to raise taxes it
seems like a great idea but in the end
every government pays the price for
doing this or more precisely its
citizens do
so the current inflation horrible as it
is is hardly unexpected you'd really
have to be a fed chairman not to have
seen it coming
what's confusing as hell is our labor
market
the unemployment rate is higher than it
was before covet not a ton but some that
means fewer people have jobs than did
two years ago labor force participation
meanwhile a slightly different
measurement is way down and that means
fewer people are working or even looking
for jobs so that's the picture on one
side of the labor market
and yet this is the truly bizarre part
we are simultaneously experiencing a
serious labor shortage so we have a
shortage of labor and a glut of labor
simultaneously
in some places businesses have shut down
because they can't find employees as you
well know if you live here so again at
the very same moment we have both too
many workers and also too few workers
that does not make sense
how can that possibly be happening
and again
we're going to be honest and tell you
we're not entirely sure how it's
happening no one is entirely sure but we
can tell you it's definitely not natural
this is not how markets are supposed to
work this is not a good sign
if you're running the country and you
were a responsible person you'd be very
concerned about a trend like this but
our leaders don't seem especially
concerned
consider lisa cook she's professor of
economics at michigan state university
cook has advised joe biden an economic
policy she's now considered a shoe-in
for an appointment to the federal
reserve board
so soon lisa cook will be one of the
people in charge of fixing this mess
how's she going to do at that job
well the early signs are not especially
promising
not long ago cook and other faculty
members at michigan state got an email
from their school quote our residential
dining halls could use your help it read
turns out food service staff weren't
showing up to work why well partly
because of the economic policies that
the white house had enacted on the
advice of lisa cook and as a result of
that the cafeterias desperately needed
faculty to pitch in and help to feed
people the most basic job of all
and yet as far as we know lisa cook
despite her perfectly suited last name
did not help
she stayed home
now in case you think we're singling out
lisa cook to be fair a lot of people are
staying home these days
they're not pitching in the number of
americans who have jobs has dropped by
nearly five million people since
february of last year
now none of these people according to
the government assessment is looking for
a new job
why
lots of reasons some of them have
retired
others have moved on to work that is
difficult for the government to keep
track of that's not always a bad thing
if you've left a soul-crushing job at
citibank to attend an organic apple
orchard kind of hard to see how that's a
net loss for society in fact we probably
should be celebrating that good for you
the problem is with all the rest
some large percentage of able-bodied
americans have just decided to stop
working at all
now in the long run
this is a big change it's not good for
the national character for example
healthy societies value work
they believe it confers dignity and
meaning
but in the short term as an economic
matter this is killing small businesses
there's a driver shortage in this
country and it's not just hitting the
transport of goods
school bus drivers are in short supply
too at nugget market the manager works
the register for a three pack tip to
cover short staffing a fact of life in
so many businesses some walgreens
pharmacy drive-throughs like this one at
maine and mason streets in green bay
have been blocked off recently
signs posted on the windows say they
don't have enough staff certain job
sectors like retail restaurants and
hospitality are understaffed
no matter how you slice it the
government has incentivized people not
to work
so it's really tough to get people to to
work and then once they're here
to stay on for more than six months
so why is this happening and again the
signs of it are
everywhere there's no room service in
your hotel in case you haven't noticed
and that's just the least of it
well one of the reasons this is
happening is because government put out
some really destructive policies here's
fox's will kane to explain
this is the kathy of bebo and kathy's so
this is the sign you had up front kathy
when we came in i don't know if you guys
can see that but we're short staffed
please be patient with the staff that
did show up no one wants to look to work
anymore we'd they would rather draw
unemployment is that is that really what
you said oh that's true that's so true
i'm so tired of all of it
quit giving all this unemployment
they're getting unemployment they're
getting the stimulus why work
they make a lot of money they're
quitting
just so they can get unemployment
so you never hear anybody on tv say that
but if you're around people with what we
used to call working class jobs you hear
it all the time you hear a lot people
are mad about it at the international
house of pancakes in wasilla alaska not
always possible to get pigs in the
blanket why well here's the message
posted on its front door due to the fact
that biden gave out way too much free
money and nobody wants to work anymore
we are forced to reduce our hours during
the week
so there is some truth in this at times
over the past two years some people were
making much more from government
unemployment benefits than they had been
making in the jobs that they left one
analysis found that thanks to the
so-called cares act restaurant workers
nearly doubled their weekly pay when
they became unemployed
the government was literally making it
more lucrative for people not to work
and stay at home that is the definition
of insanity
not only do policies like that wreck our
economy and close ihop
there's an obvious moral cost to them
what's the message the government is
sending here the message is you'd have
to be an idiot to work
so you've got to wonder what damage that
message has done to this country's
attitudes about work well here's one
measure of that damage potentially
supplemental unemployment employment
benefits ended this fall they were so
clearly nuts
and yet a lot of people didn't go back
to work in fact even more americans quit
their jobs one recent poll found that 73
percent of americans are thinking about
quitting right now and again this isn't
all bad this stuff is very complex and
we want to be honest some jobs aren't
worth having we wish people would quit
it'd be great to see a mass exodus of
say chief diversity officers from
america's corporations and liberal arts
colleges they could all learn to do tub
and tile work it would be far better off
as a country if they did we hope they
will
and also we must be honest for people
who do want to work it's a shrinking
number but some do and there's very good
news for them wages are up dramatically
particularly at the bottom end some fast
food workers are making 18 bucks an hour
plus signing bonuses and that seems like
something to celebrate but of course no
one in washington is celebrating this is
a victory for americans who don't have
college degrees and that means a defeat
for them
so in washington they're already
thinking of ways to use mass immigration
to shaft unskilled workers out of their
recent gains quote immigrants could fix
u.s labor shortage read a recent
headline in vox of course it did the
head of domino's pizza agrees he'd like
to pay his employees less and he wants
to use newly imported foreign workers to
do it how's the white house feel about
this well of course biden's on board
with it he wants more democratic voters
from foreign countries so what you're
looking at is the perfect alignment of
malignant motives so expect the borders
to stay open
but what no one in washington is
thinking about and what we should all be
thinking about is why is this happening
in the first place why are fewer people
choosing to work
and have been for a long time by the way
this is not a new trend our labor
markets are getting sicker for
generations look at this chart this is
one measure of it this shows the labor
force participation rate of american men
it goes back to 1950 71 years ago what
do you notice the line goes straight
down
now here's another chart similar but
different this is the labor force
participation rate of women in america
and that line moves in the opposite
direction
so as you can tell for 70 years we have
been losing men in the workforce
now many call this progress on the
assumption that anything that is bad and
degrading for men must be good for
america but it is not progress
it's a problem the average man defines
himself by his job yes men and women are
very different extremely different whole
society is built on their differences
every society is and the thing about men
is they kind of need to work
they tend to fall apart when they're
unemployed not all of them do but enough
of them do that we should be worried
when we see trends like this
but our leaders aren't worried heedless
as always the consequences of what they
do they've used covet to accelerate that
trend
here's one example who's hurt most by
vaccine mandates
well the group least likely to get
vaccines that of course is working-class
men
what percentage of new york times
reporters have obeyed joe biden and been
injected with the vax well probably
around a hundred percent
among men who work in oil fields that
number is closer to 10
massive difference
massive disparate effect
like a lot in american life there's
actually a class war in progress here
just beneath the surface when you fire
people for not taking an injection by
the way it doesn't work you're not
hurting the private equity people you're
hurting blue collar people and maybe
that's why they're doing it
but either way here's the core point
the incentives that we've constructed in
this country over a long period of time
to be fair but accelerating recently
have a very specific effect those
policies reward people who don't want a
job
and they punish people who do want a job
what they do is they degrade work they
strip it of its inherent meaning and
that's a problem in a country that is
running out of things that have inherent
meaning they're telling you that your
religion means nothing your patriotism
means nothing your family means nothing
now they're telling you your work means
nothing what does mean anything and how
long can a society continue
that doesn't have
meaning
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else